Taylor Sampson's mom Leaves Court after
a jury found her son was the victim of
second degree murder I just thought we
wanted we wanted first
take what we can get the verdict came
Saturday evening after about 22 to 23
hours of deliberations Sanderson had
been charged with first-degree murder in
Samson's 2015 death a jury convicted him
of that in 2017 but a new trial was
ordered on a successful appeal this time
some of sanderson's interrogation was
excluded that's when he told police
varying stories of what happened that
night the judge made decisions as to
what evidence would be admissible so
there were different rulings with
respect to evidence that we are allowed
to call in this trial it is Justice
served because a jury has heard all of
the evidence and jury has made a
decision and we respect their decision
Samson arrived at sanderson's apartment
August 15 2015 for a 20-pound marijuana
drug deal Sanderson told the jury he
shorted Sampson about thirty thousand
dollars confronted him about an alleged
prior robbery and flashed his loaded
handgun he said he shot Samson in
self-defense Crown prosecutor Carla ball
says it appears the jury rejected that
that argument Mr Sanderson will be
sentenced to life in prison this affects
the parole in eligibility we are pleased
with the result and we obviously had
argued for first degree but we are very
satisfied that the jury made the
determination and took their role
extremely seriously and we value that
the parole eligibility period will be
determined by Justice James Chipman but
the jury was able to make
recommendations one juror suggested the
minimum of 10 years while the rest
recommended 22 to 25 years that speaks
to the abhorrent nature of the crime in
our view sanderson's sentencing takes
place April 20th and 21st Samson's mom
thanked the crown for their hard work
and had some Choice words for Sanderson
he's evil he's their special place in
hell for him and that's all I got to say
Callum Smith Global News Dartmouth